you
thank you committee these will all be
going to
subcommittee so reserve your more
detailed questions
you should have been studying the
pension system since last week
this will be a refresher
hello
committee i'm here to report our to
introduce
house bill 1587
fna
i'm representative kevin pratt from
raymond i'm a retired fire chief and
firefighter of 42 years
and past senior fire brigade leader of
seabook nuclear power plant
i'm here today to introduce house bill
1587.
this bill is in regards to determining
the average final
compensation for the new hampshire group
2 retirement system
currently
the average final
compensation we'll call afc
is used as part of the calculation to
determine the annual pension members of
the retirement system receive
for those who retired
for those who were hired on or after
july 1st
or have not attended
vested status prior to january 1st
2012 the afc is
calculated by determining the average of
your highest five years base salary and
adding your career average compensation
over the basin excluding your highest
what this legislation is attempting to
do
is adjust the afc calculation for group
two to consider compensation
over base in the members highest five
years when averaging the member's entire
career of compensation over base a
members conversation over base is their
highest five years
in their highest five years will still
be compared to their compensation over
their entire career
but this legislation would ensure that
their entire career would be considered
as part of that calculation
because now five years isn't
this bill is all about fairness and this
bill is very timely
when the last big changes to group two
average final compensation was completed
it excluded the highest five years for
calculating the afc
for people under 10 years at that time
this subset of group two people are
reaching their retirement age at this
time so it's really timely to uh take
care of this at this time
and i'll
start my discussion there because
there's a lot of people here that are a
little bit better versed on this than i
am and on the financial end of it so
they awaken this waiting to speak
thank you representative pratt are there
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you
thank you and i'd call marty carlin from
thank you uh madam chair for the record
my name is marty carlin representing the
new hampshire retirement system uh nhrs
doesn't have a position on the bill uh
testifying for informational purposes
oh
you practically have to eat the
microphone
just so everybody knows that
okay is this better
okay thanks um
so i'll again for the record marty
carlin representing nhrs who does not
have a position on the bill um i signed
up to testify to provide some background
on the uh
average final compensation calculation
to help understand what this change is
about i prepared a handout which the
committee has and there were some copies
on the table for the gallery as well
basically
the pension calculation is based on
um you know years of service and average
final compensation
and um
average final and
to determine average final compensation
there's a there's something called
earnable compensation in the statute and
that lists a number of uh pay types
that count towards the pension formula
for people um base pay obviously things
like overtime holiday pay stipends um
longevity pay things like that so
up until 2012
you know all of that compensation as
long as it was considered pensionable
wages or double comp uh it was reported
to the retirement system in total you
know when contributions were assessed
for the member and the employer that way
with house bill 2 in 2011
beginning on january 1st of 2012
employers were required to report uh
base pay compensation over base pay
um
separately
so that's that's the the universe of
time where this has been in effect so
the last 11 years last 10 years
and
what the statute did at the same time
when it created this reporting was said
that for anybody who was not vested
prior to 1 one of 12 and that include
included future hires
when we go to calculate their average
final compensation their high five years
you know in their career
we have to
find the high five and then determine
the percentage of compensation over base
to base pay in the high five and so
you've got that percentage number you
put it over here and then we have to
look at the other years in their career
for which we have data on compensation
over base
and find the average in those years
outside the high five
and then the statute says we have to
apply the lower of those two percentages
to what we allow in the high five for
compensation over base so
clear is mud totally understand that um
there is a on the handout there's a
sample calculation
um you know just you know hypothetical
this is if someone had an average final
compensation of 60 000 in their high
five and 50 000 of that was base pay
and another so the remainder would have
been compensation over base
um ten thousand into fifty thousand is
twenty percent of the total afc
was um comp over base and then if you
the next uh brits at the bottom of the
first page
if the rest of the career percentage was
also 20 or greater it would not change
the afc for the high five because
the af the percentage within the high
five is lower
if it was less than that we'd have to
apply that percentage to that ten
thousand dollars of compensation over
base and the high five and that could
reduce the pension uh proportionally uh
the afc that goes into the pension
formula
what this and what this bill would do is
change that calculation as as
representative pratt said to take the
percentage within the high five
and the percentage within the entire
member's career including the high five
so um
you know this provision was part of an
omnibus bill that made
significant changes on multiple levels
to the pension plan um so you know it it
um
you know there was a lot of moving parts
um you know with the legislation that
year
um this was uh added i think as a senate
amendment um this this position and it
was it was billed as an anti-spiking uh
piece where that um if somebody only
worked additional earned additional pay
in their in their high five uh you know
there'd be um
you know a consequence in the afc
calculation to that um you know and
there wasn't to my notes or knowledge uh
recollection much discussion of the of
this issue with the the entirety versus
that um so so uh
you know there's been conversations
since then about that and this this
legislation
is spurred by that um right now we have
about 5 900 active group 2 members who
fall into this
formula and anybody you know who joins
the system in group 2 subsequently is
so
with that i can try to answer any
questions about the calculations i hope
that was helpful background
thank you mr carlin i have a question
you say that the data for compensation
over base is only available for 10 years
yes so that and presumably one's highest
five years would be in the last 10 years
of your career
typically but not always yeah okay so
that it's
so you're talking about one
five years
on one hand and the rest of the career
is also five years
in the most case
yeah for you for
you know anybody who yeah there's there
are many people in the system who that's
a very small sample size for for both
right now yes
are the other questions representative
pearson uh just just for clarity on what
you asked the reason that you only have
10 years worth of data is because prior
to 10 years ago it was not separated
you're going to continue to carry that
data forward beyond 10 years
correct yes the employer has only
reported one line of compensation so
it's not like the system just keeps 10
years worth of data it's just that they
started collecting it 10 years ago
excuse me i i i phrased it badly you're
totally i agree with you and the other
question well that's that is it wasn't
even my question that was just to
to get some clarification
for you um my actual question is during
those highest five years
that are calculated does the employee
pay in to the system based on the
earnings
that they
acquired during that period of time yeah
the employee pays in and you know in
real time every pay period or percentage
of their earnable compensation
as does the employer yeah
follow-up
is the employee refunded that money when
those five years are
taken away from the calculation are they
refunded for the portion to which they
put in
no
and i have one more madam chair
thank you
when this when this law was enacted in
2011 or when this change was made in
did this
just just for one more point of
clarification for the committee did this
retroactively apply to active employees
uh it applied to anyone who was uh not
vested prior to one one of twelve so
there was you know you know nine point
nine years and eleven months of people
who were in
uh in the system that it did apply to
other questions from the committee
all right
seeing
seeing none thank you mr carlin thank
thank you madam chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is arthur beaudry
i am the president of the new hampshire
state permanent firefighters retirement
association and i'm here in favor of
house bill 1587 fna
as presented
mr collin did a great job as far as
giving you the background of how this
happened
but when you look at it the current
legislation really is um
excuse me pretty hard with the mask um
current legislation really contradicts
itself how can you have an average of
somebody's career when you're removing a
portion of that average
so
when when this took place um
the members really lost a lot of things
if you get promoted um or you have um
you get a career
change as far as in your employment that
affects all your all your salary also so
and a lot of times i know in police and
fire um you might get promoted you know
in your last five years and that should
be included
in in the calculations and um
when when when you they take a portion
of that away from you i had some uh data
and i'm trying to find it before i got
called in but
i i will i will present it that you can
get a firefighter prior to
2012 work the exact same amount of hours
as somebody that worked after 2012
and and make
more money
a lot more money than that individual
even though they both contributed the
exact same amount of money into the
system
so again it's a it's a equity and
fairness issue
and this bill has been brought before
you on more than one occasion and it
seems like it was stopped in finance
but the savings when when they have a
fiscal note on this the only savings
that the system is saving is on the
backs of the retire of the person
retiring the member because that member
should be actually getting that
portion of their salary that they're
they're being
neglected to to get because of this
change so again if you're going to go
with an average of a person's career it
should be
an average of all the years of service
and i will take any questions
thank you mr beaudry representative
lackas
uh thank you madam chair um
if i understood you correctly you were
saying that um
you know if they got a raise near the
end that that
because it uh
was in that last five years it
it would not contribute to their
uh retirement benefits but as i read
this
the limitation which deals with you know
what period is things are averaged over
applies to
compensation above the base pay i assume
if somebody gets a raise they
are a promotion they get a raise
and it's my understanding unless i'm
that that increase in in base pay would
contribute to the retirement is that not
correct it does but when you get
promoted
your extra details um if you have um
you're mustering outpay that's all
that's all part of that salary of um of
your promotion
um
you'll be available for the subcommittee
mr beaudry i hope so i hope i don't uh
get sick again but yes i will i will
hopefully your intention is to
participate if you can yes thank you
thank you
representative pierce thank you thank
you
mr botery for coming here you are a
an extraordinary wealth of historical
knowledge and that to which is is the
question i ask
um
i wasn't in the legislature when this
when this
repair this fix was presented in years
past
and i've so i'm not overly familiar but
my understanding is that when this was
calculated years ago the fiscal note was
substantially different than it is now
do you happen to know what the fiscal
note was on this in in years past
i don't i know i know the number was
somewhat high but again it it it's
because of
and i don't know how why it is so high
because really it's it's money that
should be paid to the employee um they
worked it as you stated the question uh
that you
uh had brought forward you paid into the
system on this money um so again it's
like taxation without representation
you're paying into something but you're
thank you mr baudery other questions
seeing none
thank you
good morning
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name for the record is
brian rill and i serve as the president
of the professional firefighters in new
hampshire
and i'm also a captain for the city of
portsmouth fire department
as the preeminent firefighter
organization in new hampshire we
advocate for the brave men and women
that protect the citizens of this great
state
i am testifying today in support of
house bill 1587 relative to
determination of the average final
compensation under the retirement system
today i speak to you not only as the
proud leader of some of the bravest men
and women in our state
but also someone who has a profound
concern
over the future of public safety in new
hampshire
a noble calling that was once highly
desirable is now suffering from an
epidemic like none it's ever seen
in the mid to late 2000s new hampshire's
firefighter state entrance exam
otherwise known as the candidate
physical agility test
was seeing well over 500 candidates
annually
many of whom touted a brand new fire
science degree or a paramedic
certificate
making them highly marketable to the
average fire department
in spite of this most struggled to find
a job in what was once a highly
competitive market
now the very same test yields
approximately 60 percent fewer
candidates leaving many fire departments
unable to hire enough qualified
applicants to fill their open positions
last april the number of candidates
reach an all-time low with a mere 39
candidates taking the quarterly tests
you may be left asking yourself what has
changed
a poll of our members shows that the
erosion of their retirement benefit is
atop the list of reasons that they have
left their careers in public service
or are considering doing so
in 2011 the legislative legislature
voted to make monumental changes to the
new hampshire retirement system in an
attempt to correct years of under
funding
these changes negatively impacted the
retirement security of public employees
in new hampshire drastically changing
the lives of hundreds of firefighters
since that time recruitment numbers have
consistently trended downward and fire
chiefs are finding it extremely
difficult to retain qualified
firefighters that once saw their
pensions cut in half
we rely on our firefighters to show up
during the worst moments of our lives
they were there to combat the opioid
crisis
they remain on the front lines
protecting our communities in the midst
of a global pandemic
and they continue to respond to
catastrophic events when the result is
often a diagnosis of cancer
post-traumatic stress disorder or
cardiovascular disease
those who continue to answer the call do
so with honor and grace they are aware
of the many inherent risks of this
profession
but facing the risk of being unable to
retire on a livable wage
is one that many are no longer willing
to take
firefighters are now beginning to weigh
the benefits of doing a job they love
versus the cost of doing so
it is clear that the changes to the
retirement system 10 years ago caused a
ripple effect through new hampshire's
fire service
creating a systemic problem that can
only be fixed with a systemic solution
adjusting the average final compensation
calculation does not provide an enticing
new benefit
but it simply restores a small piece of
what was taken from our first responders
and takes a step towards providing this
solution
currently firefighters pay 11.8 percent
to the retirement system on every single
dollar that they earn in order to fund
their own benefit
yet current law prevents their highest
five years of compensation over base
from being included in their pension
calculation altogether
this means that firefighters called on
to fill the void in new hampshire
are working longer hours
spending more time away from their
families and exposing themselves to
additional risks to protect the citizens
of this state
and as a thanks for their service
they're told that that work may actually
be excluded from their retirement uh
calculation
by making this small change a member's
benefit will be a more honest
representation representation of their
careers
firefighters affected by the sweeping
changes to the retirement system in 2011
are now becoming retirement eligible
and realizing that they cannot afford to
retire at all
this has created a narrative in new
hampshire that is uninviting and
unsustainable
it is time to show your firefighters
that as much as you rely on them they
can rely on you and they're listening
now more than ever
please join the 800 citizens
of this great state that have signed on
in support of this bill
and show firefighters that you're
listening to
i implore the members of this committee
to do what is right for new hampshire's
fire service and support hb 1587.
thank you madam chair and i'll entertain
any questions
thank you mr reel are there questions
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair um you say that
currently right now
uh
group two employees pay eleven point
something percent
but didn't used to be nine and three
quarter percent at one particular time
and that rise now is taken away also too
that was done one
changed about whatever and did it affect
the uh spendable income it was in 11.
as part of the changes in the complete
overhaul of the retirement system okay
thank you madam chair
and sir for the record too um
firefighters 11.8 contribution is the
highest of the public employees in new
hampshire
thank you other questions
seeing none
i'm here representing chapter 24 of the
sca as the chapter president
i've worked for the new hampshire
department of corrections for the past
17 years
my first 14 years as an officer in the
i was already working for the state for
approximately seven years when the
retirement was changed it went from
being based on our three best years
along with a few other benefits
and they changed it to our best five
years as we were told minus some
benefits
based on calculations because
retirement's not actually based on our
five years
i personally stand to lose approximately
thirteen hundred dollars a month when i
retire in five years
the truth is that we were lied to we
weren't provided all the information
we can still go online we can still find
information that was provided to us ten
years ago that said five best years
now that some of us are starting to look
at retirement we've learned that we were
deceived throughout my career the state
has tried to balance the budget on our
backs
we are citizens of new hampshire and we
don't deserve being deceived and to
state employees we deserve better the
people in this room keep this state
running smoothly and safely
the state already suffers from
understaffing it's time to start making
smarter decisions to keep employees and
to attract new employees
i believe this bill will benefit the
state and its employees
thank you
thank you are there questions
seeing none
thank you very much
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today
my name is jed carpentier and i'm here
to encourage you to vote in favor of
house bill 1587.
i'm going to share a little personal
story with you i'm a 41 year old i live
in exeter new hampshire with my wife and
three daughters i'm currently serving in
my 15th year as a professional
firefighter in the town of hampton i'm a
first generation firefighter in fact i
hadn't given much thought
to becoming a firefighter until
september 11 2001 on that day i was a 21
year old marine stationed in okinawa
japan i disappear i witnessed the
bravery displayed by many americans that
day and it made me realize that there
are men and women dedicated to a higher
calling in every community in america
and soon we would be needing more of
them
when my time was up in the marines i
made the trip home to start my training
to become a firefighter
while i was doing that i worked in
private business for several years while
i took my fire and medical classes on
nights and weekends i declined an offer
for a management position with my
company with a nice salary and benefit
package to pursue my goal of serving the
public as a firefighter
when i began interviewing to become a
full-time firefighter i found it to be
an extremely competitive process
there were limited vacancies and when a
position opened it would be ex it was it
would be extremely competitive
it was common to see dozens of
candidates
applying for one position now you see
the same positions being posted
repeatedly and maybe even a hiring bonus
attached to it in an attempt to attract
qualified candidates
my story is not unique
many of my fellow firefighters had other
career opportunities where they would
make more money in the private sector
and they too declined those
opportunities in pursuit of a career in
public safety
coming into this profession you are
aware that firefighting is an unyielding
you are aware of the obvious dangers
that await you but it is unlikely that
you would be aware of the grim
statistics associated with your career
we respond to help people on their worst
days frequently exposing ourselves to
carnage the human mind struggles to
process and that's validated through the
increased rate of ptsd amongst
firefighters our members put themselves
in hazardous environments to protect the
public we serve
unfortunately this too can be validated
through the increased rate of cancer
among firefighters
with these with the increased awareness
regarding the health and safety concerns
associated with our profession
accompanied with the added cost pushed
down onto employees by the legislature
in 2011 and the reduction in the benefit
at the end of your career you have to
wonder
who are we going to be able to attract
to do these careers in public safety
if we don't value these positions
we should be careful of our expectation
out of these positions in the future
a vote in favor of house bill 1587 is an
ethical decision to allow a return on
the 11.8 percent of their hard-earned
wages they paid towards their retirement
thank you for your testimony
i don't see any questions
yes representative schmidt you will you
be able to support the subcommittee
well that wasn't going to be my question
in this instance
if they haven't heard of the first 30
times
they're not going to hear it
you are obviously
reading from a prepared statement and i
encourage you and the others who are
having uh prepared statements to present
to us to
either send us or provide a copy so that
we can see this
uh
your eloquent words and story uh are
moving in and as a former marine who
served on okinawa myself
um uh congratulations and semper fi
are there any technical questions no
thank you
uh
the case i call
and i and i apologize for my broken
english it's my sixth language
so
good morning
david
my name is seif uragasa i represent the
new hampshire chief prohibition parole
officers i am the
i'm the president for the command staff
uh when back in 2011 they
established a new law that uh require
members to contribute so at 11.5
i was about nine years and eight months
to the state service so this bill affect
me personally and
many others
in many different levels and
until this day it continued to affect us
uh in a way it is it creates a parity
issue where
employees that basically went to the
same academy with me because they were
hired three months prior to me they
contributed the same money
they served the same agency they went to
the same academy but those employees can
keep they can pay
what is required by the state to pay but
they are able to
have their highest
three
years included no five years three years
whereas myself and many others are told
that now we're changing
the system and you will be affected
retroactively even though you're nine
years and ten months
we understand that we won't be honoring
what we honor for other employees
therefore we have a new paying system
for you where you will pay high
will collect that money but that money
won't go towards to your retirement or
in determining
the highest five years
um
i don't understand how the state even
can do away with that probably it was
from the advertisement that was in the
state retirement website and you guys
can view it until this day it says your
five
five highest year compensation
yeah
sure do you want me to bring this to you
so you can see it
yes
many of us uh the first affected group
learned about this in 2020 so when they
changed it not only they changed it
but then they started spreading
business information where you can keep
still your five highest year for most
people including myself
highest year highest five years highest
three years really wasn't that much so
we were okay to live with it
but unfortunately when we learn what it
means and how it is interpreted
as you can see a house room
room full of public servants and many of
them who couldn't be here and this is
going to be a season where we all will
come up and ask lawmakers and what
exactly happened to so fast we were told
hired under certain condition
not only you increase our compensation
payment now
you're changing the years how many years
will contribute now
the money that we are contributing you
can legally take them but then it won't
be calculated it's a hard pill to
swallow so
i'm here in support of the bill i
support uh
those who have the initiative to serve
to write this bill
and bring it and if anything i mean it
won't fix
most of the problem we have but it is a
start
to give back to
the responders and as you all know the
people who are affected by this bill are
law enforcement officers and
firefighters
who are first responders who hope to
answer all the emergencies we have
including covet
so
i would
i would ask for your support
and i'll take any question
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
good morning
my name is frank swerko i'm a parole and
probation officer for the state i
currently work out of the manchester
district office
i like to note that
the manchester district office consists
of 13 probation parole officers who
supervise
case loads of approximately
anywhere from 100 to 150 convicted
drug users dealers rapists murderers
and
gang bangers
our entire caseload is our convicted
offenders you can imagine the toll that
that can take when your entire career is
based
on dealing with these type of
individuals
um
i am also
a member of the
executive board of nhpa and i'm
president of the new hampshire probation
and parole officers association
i've worked for the department of
corrections for 15 years now
and i've
some faith i've grown up with family who
worked in law enforcement and i know
for a fact that people have come from
all over the country to come work as a
first responder in law enforcement
in this state
it's largely based because of the
benefits at the time and the good
retirement system that we had here i
don't think you see that anymore i think
that the instability of the retirement
system is concerning to people and i
think it is a driving force behind the
recruitment and retention issues i think
that new hampshire has been
fortunate in that there have been no
big incidents that have made national
headlines i think it's largely because
of the
quality of people that new hampshire has
attracted over the years
as with anything else i think you get
what you pay for
in life
that being said uh when this change came
to fruition in 2012 i was not very
educated i was still young i didn't
understand the ramifications of it all
but i've in recent years i have done my
best to try to educate myself and
understand the system
and the flaws and the reasons for the
proposed changes back in 2012
and when i sit and think about them i
i can almost understand them almost
but then i think one thing that i often
think is president when i deal with
issues
and and that is what's right is
right in my time as president i've dealt
with number issues and i
when considering them i just try to
decide if
if this
fight or this position is
principally right and if it's reasonable
to everybody involved
and this fight this issue this bill is
we support on behalf of the probation
parole officers association i support
this bill not because
it fixes what was taken from us in 2012
but because a step in the right
direction to
remedy what
to assist
the
the hard-working
first responders
who have upheld their
part of the bargain since day one thank
you
i'll take any questions if anybody has
any thank you for your testimony
representative schuett
thank you madam sir mr starco
there is a question
yes sorry about that good morning um
i believe you said you
work with eight other officers
there are a total of 13 in manchester
specifically okay and is that a full
compliment
or
should there be more technically there
should definitely be more that's an
ongoing issue that we attempt to address
within the department and state
and
i assume that there have been efforts to
hire more um yes what kind of response
have you gotten uh we've
a slow one but there is increasing
attempts and we've gotten a couple of
offices here here and there over the
last few years
nowhere near is
enough but
you know we do what we can we do the
best we can and we we enjoy it we take
pride in our work
and we'll continue to work hard
thank you
thank you for answering our questions
good gija
thank you madam chairman
and committee members please move closer
to the mic
my name is michael gea i'm the president
of the new hampshire police association
and i'm here today to convey our support
to house bill 1587.
you have heard from others who testified
before me as to what this bill does
i want to take just a few minutes to
explain to you why this bill is so
important to law enforcement throughout
our state
first let me say that 10 years ago when
numerous changes were made to the
state's retirement program it was
impossible to anticipate the
circumstances that would develop like we
have today
but some of these changes laid the
foundation for hiring and retention
problems by altering provisions and
benefits that had been agreed to when
some members were hired
fast forward to 2022
the state of new hampshire and just
about every city and town are facing
serious employment challenges in the
public safety area
especially law enforcement a state
police have dozens of unfilled positions
and local communities are finding the
applicant pool to be extremely tight
with that cities and towns are
competing against each other for not
only the limited number of new hires but
in retaining existing personnel
competition from other states
the private sector
and in some cases outright burnout
are adding to this very concerning
public safety problem
i want you to know that there is a very
concerning out of the ordinary trend
developing
the number of employees who are leaving
before they reach their 20 or 25 years
is very real that is something none of
us could have contemplated just a few
years ago
the one tool that can help address this
problem is strengthening the retirement
benefits so there is incentive to stay
for the full term
we believe hb 1587 is the kind of tool
that will help in retaining those
individual who might be thinking about
leaving early
and quite frankly the economics makes
sense local communities spend an average
about 50 000 or more to train certify
and equip
each new police officer
each time one leaves the new hire
training costs hit local budgets and
that's if the local community can even
find new hires
we are very fortunate in this state to
have such a dedicated skilled and
qualified group of law enforcement
officers
but the challenges are there for the
future i ask you to think hard about
this potential crisis and to act before
it gets worse
we all need to do everything possible to
encourage these individuals to work
their full pre-retirement terms
that's good for the safety of our
citizens in every community keep in mind
being a police officer today is a
challenging stressful job it is a noble
profession it's something i truly love
but every minute on the job is filled
with safety concerns house bill 1587
will help our state and local
communities in their recruitment and
retention of qualified police officers i
urge you to support this bill thank you
thank you for your testimony
are there any questions from the
committee representative o'brien
thank you thank you for taking my
question
you you said conor in your testimony
that this community is finding a hard
time can potential candidates and i i
don't know if you heard i i'm on the
board of aldermen and nashua as the
example uh we're discussing hiring a 500
you know paying a 500 bonus to get
police officers how much of as an impact
do you really think that this is really
affecting people looking for this type
of career
there's a lot of concerns today with law
enforcement there's a lot of policy
changes there's a lot of things that's
being implemented
and you have to think about it this way
22 year old coming in to work as a
police officer he's got 25 years at the
end of the day what is his retirement is
going to be after he's done his 25 years
500 dollars fi a signing bonus
is a probably a catching uh statement
however
you might have a problem uh certifying
the individual
however he is going to be leaving in a
couple years after that because he is
going to be
made a little bit more aware of what his
retirement compensation at the end of
his 25 years
very good thank you thank you
other questions
representative
thank you so what you're saying is it's
not maybe a matter of initial hiring but
in
a matter of retention of officers and
firemen they go hand in hand
hiring and retention is a problem right
now
i work for salem pd i'm a detective with
salem pd
i remember when i took the test there
was about 300 applicants
today we're lucky to have 25
and don't forget there's background
excessive background everything that
they have to go through for out of the
ten you might end up with two to three
people
okay
well thank you for for your testimony
other questions
seeing none
claudia cass
i have some copies here for the group
thank you very own thank you very much
thank you i want to thank you for having
us all here today an opportunity to
speak to you
i'm officer claudia cass i've been
working for the department for almost 16
years now i was one of the people that
was hired under the original deal
i know there's been some
efforts to
bring everyone up to speed on how this
all came to be
obviously the pension system was
terribly underfunded
it was underfunded before i was hired it
was underfunded in part because
municipalities enjoyed a tax holiday and
did not pay into the pension system it
was underfunded because the market had a
terrible crash
but i was hired with a deal that i would
work 20 years
and i would have my best three years
and i would be able to bank out my sick
in my vacation time and i would pay
9.75 percent into the pension system
in 2011 they changed that retroactively
i had almost six years with the
department
i was sentenced to three years in prison
i have to work three years that's about
the average sentence
for
maybe your second drug crime or
your second sex offense i get to stay in
prison because the legislature reneged
on a deal a promise it was made to me
although in fairness that bill never
passed that bill did not pass it was
christmas tree down to house bill 2 the
funding bill
and that's how we got sentenced to
prison
we have to serve more i have to pay two
percent more into the pension system
because the state shifted that onus to
me
not only did i not get a benefit i lost
benefits
but ever since 2011 i've sucked it up i
was told it was my best five years
and then i would have to serve 23 years
needless to say this has not helped our
recruitment and our retention we have
dropped our retirement age we've
given raises we've done everything
possible and we can't recruit people
because
well he spoke of 25 years we were
dropped over to our hiring age to 20
year olds
they have to work 33 years to collect
their pension and even with this bill
their pension is capped at twice their
base salary their base salary doesn't
include weekends
does include weekend differential
doesn't include shift differential
doesn't include hazardous duty pay
so they will pay in these guys are
getting forced four to five times a week
i don't know how many of you are aware
of the staffing crisis that we have at
the state prison
but we can't staff it and we had 20
this bill
does
almost nothing frankly
almost nothing thanks for
including the years that i'm paying into
the pension system anyway in my
calculation it's not a gift it's a tiny
return on the money i'm already paying
and you know how poorly educated we are
i who have probably done the most since
i'm close to leaving
i found out today
today that i'm not going to be refunded
over 20 000 dollars that i paid into the
pension system over and above what
they're going to calculate my pension on
i was told
by the new hampshire retirement system
that anything that wasn't used towards
my
calculation was going to be refunded
so literally today sitting here and
hearing them testify is the first i have
ever been told i'm not going to get my
so
it is an election yeah the state got 1.8
billion dollars
in the stimulus package for covet belief
over 600 million of that went to the
municipalities the same municipalities
that started this under funding in the
first place and i'm certain they're
going to come here and speak
against paying for the first responders
that have protected them all these
years so i just want to make mention of
that and i also
was called to read in my paper
that the same legislature
paid 20 million dollars to the victims
this is the same legislature that we're
asking to give us
our own money in a calculation
so i frankly feel this is the very least
that you could do
is give us our own money that we work
for and paid into the pension system as
part of the calculation
i'll take any questions you might have
and i says not written scribbles
okay
thank you very much for your testimony
representative pearson
thank you madam chair
you mentioned
mandatory overtime
yes sir when you were when you were
addressing us
um
can you elaborate as to what what
exactly mandatory
means
mandatory means you can't go home
means at the end of your shift they tell
you you have to stay for eight more
the average
um i i don't have this specific numbers
with me perhaps someone else here does
but it's literally thousands of hours a
week that we have to cover
to try and get the prison staffed when i
started we had i believe the number was
around 800 correctional officers
and i think we're down to around 400
we're at 50 of the staffing we're
supposed to have at the men's prison in
concord
and then we're also required to cover
the other prisons so if women's prison
needs staffing we have to go up there
and staff that as well
so we all have to cover all the hours
there's a prison to run we have what's
called critical minimum and most days we
cannot even meet our critical minimum by
forcing every single body that we have
available
now we are they have made some changes
in the probation parole officers are
allowed to help us now but their best
five years are tossed so for years they
weren't allowed to help us and now that
they are allowed to help us people
like you know seifu or swarko they have
already spoken in their best five years
they
took the initiative to come and help us
fill a staffing crisis and those five
years are going to be tossed and it's
going to be based on the years that they
weren't even allowed to help us so
they're paying into the pension system
on a benefit
that they overwhelmingly benefited all
of us
and they're not even going to be able to
collect on that
okay have a follow-up
thank you madam chair
so what i'm getting in summation because
i have
no idea what your world looks like
in
corrections
you are being forced to work against
your will
money is being taken out of your
paycheck
for doing so and then you're told
sorry that we forced you into what
someone almost described as slave labor
and we're not going to count that that's
the summation of what you're getting at
right that is absolutely correct when i
was hired we didn't have as much
overtime we had a lot more staff the
women's prison wasn't open this current
women's prison requires a lot more
staffing than the previous women's
prison which has exasperated our
underfunding our understaffing rather so
now i do get forced more than i ever
would have in the beginning of my career
but i was under the impression it was
going to be my best five up until
summer of 2021 i know saifu said 20 i
did not know until 2021 when i went to
run my numbers that my top five years
are tossed
so these years and these times and these
hours have been stolen from my family
and my money has been stolen from my
check
and i had no idea
that i was never going to benefit from
it
thank you for your testimony ms cass
other questions representative schmidt
you are working with some kind of a
document can you uh provide us that with
that
can you read scribble sir
i literally scribbled a couple of little
notes um on the bottom of your paper
have a i'm sorry
can really have a doctor
all right that's the last card is there
any other member of the public that
no
they're not paying any of this
this is all funded from the state not
the municipalities representative yakuba
this bill will be going to your
subcommittee
and uh please
we'll let you know when the
subcommittee meetings are
you know
since no one else wishes to testify i'll
close the public hearing
on
1587. and open the public hearing on
house bill 1557
and
representative goalie who will will
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
for the record representative jeff
goalie representing hillsborough 8
manchester ward 1
here today to introduce house bill 1557
relative to survivor benefit optional
and the reason i'm bringing this forward
um i contacted
the hampshire retirement system
i retired
back in
2021 november 2021
and
no
november 2020 and when
i get my
final
uh calculations for the system what
happens is when you retire
they
send your first checks based on
what they calculate
um for your average compensation
and they wait to get your final numbers
from the city or town that you retired
from so that they can calculate your
final overall compensation of what your
benefit will be going forward
when you retire they don't have that all
in front of them they have to wait and
get the
vacation time your sick time accruals
and all that calculated in later on down
and it usually
in normal years it takes
two maybe three months at the most for
this to happen
well
when i retired
in the middle of covered
i didn't get my final numbers
uh i retired in november first
i paperwork may 12th
six months later
and on that paperwork it says within 120
days after the effective date of your
retirement you may elect to change or
cancel an option by notifying new
hampshire retirement system
i got this six months later saying i
only had four months if i chose to
change my benefit once i get my final
numbers so i called the retirement
system this was in statute there was
nothing they could do there was no
exemptions
it wasn't a ruling that they could go
forward and say well this is extenuating
circumstances to where we're at
so i asked them if there was a way to
change that to
make it
you could change it up to the 120 days
after you receive your final numbers
to give you that option
and
this is the language they came up with
that's in this bill
um marty's here
i think it'll do what i want but i i'm
not sure i just i just want to make sure
that
a member is basing their final option
uh that they choose based on their final
calculation that they have in front of
them from the retirement system so
that's why i brought this forward and
that's why we're here
thank you representative goalie it
are there any questions for
okay it doesn't look like any questions
uh thank you
thank you madam chair again for the
record marty carlin representing nhrs
we don't have a position on this bill
however
representative goalie summed up the the
issue at hand quite well the statute
currently
gives a member member
120 days
after retirement to change their
survivorship option what a survivorship
option is
is the opportunity to leave some or all
of a pension benefit to a beneficiary if
they pass away
if a member takes the maximum amount
it's a lifetime benefit for that person
but they can designate you know fifty
percent to someone else or a hundred
percent and there's some other uh
permutations called pop-up options uh
and basically once that election is made
after after the 120 days after
retirement there are very limited
circumstances under which it can be
adjusted
after that there's a couple of
exceptions for death of a spouse
um or um you know divorce and the
divorce decree doesn't
award the pension to uh to the ex uh
type of thing but pretty much you're
locked in um and with that 120 day
limit in the statute our goal
is has been to try to get all benefits
finalized within 120 days
however there are times of the year
where a backlog builds up
july is our busiest month because pretty
much all the teachers retire
at the end of their contract year so
that
you know
it's probably four times more than the
next highest month and you know five or
six times higher than other months you
know we can't can't staff for the year
for that one month so we things get
behind and also we have issues sometimes
with employers not sending in all these
trailing wages or the proper termination
forms that was
the the nexus of the bill last week that
you heard house bill 1318 it's sort of
part of the same coin uh is is the issue
representative um
goalie brought forth here um
and
you know he did reach out to us with
what his specific intention was and the
language in the bill is something we
looked at and
found you know we could administer
six and seven just to reference
date of the original notice of
retirement uh provided by the retirement
system not to include any future benefit
adjustments that may be carried out and
what that is is you know
occasionally
somebody retires in months or even years
after uh you know an audit issue
comes up and um
you know there's a pension adjustment so
we wanted to have that language in so
it's that initial finalization notice
and if some something else turns up
later it doesn't you know five years
down the road they couldn't change their
option
you know we are comfortable that we can
administer
this um provision as written
and
you know manage that
you know without any additional issue
be glad to answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
representative fellows
uh yes could you just tell me
when um
during their career
a person who's
eligible for the retirement system when
during their career can they make this
change can they make it just at
any time
not not i'm not really focused on at the
very end when they retire but throughout
can they make that change and about how
how often does that happen uh
active members or you know or people who
have yet to retire can change their best
beneficiary designation at any point you
know in their career they just would
fill out a new form um and either um you
know and get it to us and the most you
know the valid notarized form most
recently have on file is in effect
um
you know that that that would enable if
the member passes away
um the beneficiary to to
um receive death benefits in the statute
actually the next bill being heard um
doesn't it isn't analogous to this bill
but it touches on the same statute and
would change
what benefits are available to
beneficiaries if an active member passes
away but while you're still working you
can
change your beneficiary at any point and
once you retire if you took the maximum
amount for instance or or another
another non
option that doesn't continue on as a
benefit you could change that
beneficiary afterwards as well but that
person would only be
eligible for a lump sum benefit so um
you know pretty much this after the 120
days
uh you know you're pretty much locked
into that beneficiary they that
beneficiary does have the option to
renounce the benefit uh on their own if
they want to
but after retirement you're more locked
into your beneficiary but pre-retirement
you can change it you know every other
day
um we
people do change their beneficiaries we
encourage them to um especially because
you know if you filled out that
beneficiary form when you were hired you
may have had a lot of life events you
know in the ensuing years family
marriage divorce anything like that we
want to make sure
the person you intend to receive
yes
representative fellows they're talking
about whether your survivor
should you die after retirement will get
your will get the same amount as you did
or whether it'll only be half or a
quarter
it's
yes and so it's not complicated if the
per if the employee
dies before they retire that's
straightforward because if just whatever
name they have in the business
but i believe that if you choose say a
hundred percent
of your pension goes to your survivor
the pension you'll receive is less than
it would be otherwise to account for
that just actually actuarial actually
balanced
other questions
right seeing none thank you
thank you and art beaudry wishes to
testify
again good morning madam chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is arthur beaudry i represent
the new hampshire state permanent
firefighters retirement association and
i'm here in favor of house bill 1557
it just be brief choosing an option when
you retire is a big decision
for you and your family and it's a
lifetime decision
and it shouldn't be made lightly all the
information needed to make that decision
should be
at uh available to the member prior to
making that decision
and this bill shouldn't cost any
additional dollars because the um
as
the the chairman mentioned when when you
take an option you can take a a straight
annuity where you don't cover your
spouse you could take a 50 option you
can take uh 100 option where she would
get or he would get 100 of your benefit
and then you can take pop-ups and each
one of those options cost
so much money
and
not having the final numbers to make
that decision could really play an
impact to your family so
this bill is really a straightforward
piece of legislation where it is no cost
and it really helps the member make a
decision for for their families
and just don't get confused with the
death benefit
and a pension benefit because the death
benefit's going to be coming up if you
die while you're working
and you didn't you have to have 20 years
of service you can sign a form and your
your spouse will get 50 percent of your
benefit if you didn't sign that form
your spouse would get your money back in
interest and and
pretty much uh i shouldn't say that's it
but yeah um we're looking at if um you
know where you can get a hundred percent
of that benefit and that's going to be
coming up but there's two different
things a death benefit and then your
your pension benefit for your spouses
and i will take any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
it seems like we've covered this one
already thank you okay
is there anyone else who wishes to
okay seeing none i'll close the public
hearing
and we have a bit of time before our
representative lekkis suggests that we
could vote on the spill already do you
have a motion
uh yes i'd like to move otp on house
bill 1557
hi second seconded by representative
grod okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
i i think we covered everything pretty
much it's just a very straightforward
thing that uh
people should have the information they
need to make a decision like this enough
time to make it and they shouldn't lose
that opportunity because the retirement
system isn't able to get the information
to them
in the required amount of time
representative
thank you it seems prudent to the
employer employee to have the
information that they need before they
need to make before they make the
decision
i just want to make sure i understand uh
what was being said there
so currently after they receive
notice of return or give notice of
retirement whatever the trigger is
employees have 120 days
to make the decision
if there's a screw-up
and they don't get that in from they
don't get their paperwork
they have to hope they made the correct
decision with incomplete information
they're stuck and after that
um period of time
are they
um stuck with that decision for the
entirety of their retirement as mr
carlin said you can only change your
survivorship benefit in very rare
and special circumstances a divorce
right right that's what i understand oh
they're stuck just wanted to make sure
because it seems fairly common sense to
me so
i mean the
okay comments questions
all right seeing none
the motion is ought to pass on house
bill 1557. and the clerk can call the
roll
yes
representative rhodes votes yes the
he is
um representative yakubovic yes
representative leckus yes representative
allegro
representative bailey
yes
representative
no
representative goalie
yes representative showed
yes representative
schmidt
yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes
representative
grota yes
representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes
six
fourteen
that's about right
15 yes
14 to 1.
yes
okay and motion passes 14 to 1.
represents something assassin will you
be writing a minority report
uh yes and no objection to consent
what's that you know objection to
consent okay that's fine we'll put this
on i'll write the majority report unless
okay
i'm
pretty sure 1587 will not be quite that
easy
so i
will take it take a break before the
i
personally don't understand why it takes
that long
what difference does it make what your
exact last number is going to be
i don't need that but
if
it sounds like the
problem
about how brave people are
it's all gone
oh yeah hi
so
you know yesterday i
is
so
financial integration or management of
well i'm just thinking i don't know
exactly what i don't have a specific
word
yeah
the light recently especially recently
is that
we
were so focused on this being an option
that occurred when you were eligible to
retire we never really thought about
what happens to those that pass away
before that eligibility occurs
so what this bill does is it basically
says look um
you know what we there's no reason to
wait until you're eligible to retire to
simply fill out a form as to what your
plans are
and that's all this does is it opens
this up
to
for you to have the ability to do this
now currently on line three
it mentions any member upon joining the
retirement system or any member who has
reached retirement service age we have
been made aware that that really does
kind of leave a gap in the middle for
existing employees
um
and that will certainly need to be
quickly amended and i'll either tom or
my representative lanzar or myself will
be happy to make sure that gets taken
care of but we certainly don't want to
leave a gap the
the gap that we have right now has kind
of put us in this situation to begin
with so
um i just i just want to bring that to
you to your uh attention here so
certainly don't be
don't be overly concerned with all the
legalese here but this is just this just
basically outlines what you see below is
the procedure so and that's really not
changing it's just it's just a matter of
when you're going to feel your or your
thank you are there questions
representative lucas
thank you um
just to
to clarify something so there was a
discussion during an earlier bill about
you know people can specify their
beneficiary and change it at any time
how does that differ
from i mean is this this obviously is
different but what is this versus that
so what happens when you go to retire
and you look at your options
you are not solely looking at your
options
because your spouse must agree and sign
off to that option
and
that is something that
in this particular case if you are going
to do this like i was i was
not married when i entered into the
system but two years later i was
i would have been able to come in and
sit down with my wife and look at this
and say you know what as of right now
this is this is how we want this to
unfold and that way in the event that i
pass away
we're where we need to be if i pass away
beforehand but but in order to make a
change later let's you know let's say we
review this when i am eligible to retire
and
she and i think something different
should pas you know should
be the way we do things then we have the
option to change that
at that point
follow-up
that that doesn't get to to what i'm
wondering um
there was a discussion
about you know there's some sort of um
you know survivor benefit
that people are currently able to
apparently specify
before they retire and change at any
time
how is that different from the thing
this controls so
so what happens as of right now is until
you are eligible to retire that
paperwork is not
is not filled out
this is a little bit different
it's a little bit different area this
this has to do with the pension benefit
that you get
and it's not has nothing to do with
being killed in the line of duty or that
sort of thing
a good quick follow-up
okay so the one the the one that was
being mentioned before is
for uh the death benefit not for
anything with retirement yeah this this
particular bill 1497 has nothing to do
with death benefits no but i mean the
prior discussion i wasn't here for the
prior discussion this this is about
pre-selecting your
essentially your survivorship benefit
prior to being eligible to retire so
that you could do it say after you got
married
or whenever
i mean without necessarily being
eligible what's confusing me is there
was a discussion from mr carlin
about
some kind of selection that could be
done at any time and ongoing and i just
don't understand perhaps we should wait
for mr carlin to explain since he's the
next speaker so so i'll give you
representative like i'll give you a real
example here a guy that i worked with in
manchester passed away
right before
actually well one of them was before one
of them was after they were eligible
they'd never filled the paperwork out
with this with the state that caused a
significant problem with his spouse
trying to figure out how this was all
going to work
so this just gives the ability
for us to just fill the paperwork out
sooner that's really it there's no
increased benefit it doesn't it doesn't
so
let me see if i understand this
from my i'm going to compare it to my
retirement
so when i retired
i had an option of taking my retirement
package as one lump sum
or i could have it spaced out and as an
annuity
that's an example of the kinds of
decisions that you're talking about
making
before you actually retire so that
if and it's done in conjunction with
your spouse
so that if something happens to you
before you retire before you retire
then there's a plan
for those benefits
and they're outlined by you and your
spouse before something happens to you
is that what you're saying yeah so what
happens is there there's a list of
choices that the retirement system
presents to you and it involves
are you willing to take a reduced
benefit for survivorship of a spouse you
know or
or your spouse is willing to not do that
at all and you take a much higher
benefit but if you pass away it
disappears
so
the you you don't get to sit down and
dictate this the retirement system has
has choices and you and your and your
spouse will
pick whichever one is is you think is
the best for you but as under current
law you cannot do that until you're
eligible to retire
and if you pass away beforehand this
then we get the mess that we've been
dealing with
the last couple of years
follow up madam chair
so are you are you all does this bill
also
allow for you to change those things
as um
or you only get one shot at it let's say
you know
you do it when you're first married and
then 20 years later you decide you want
something else because you know life is
different and
modify it as you get older
that's a fantastic question for mr
carlin but my understanding is that in
you don't lock this in until you
actually retire okay thank you i'm sure
he can expound on that much better than
i can okay thank you
okay other questions
representative bailey
so the prior one where they where they s
the prior one where they said uh
you could change it at any time
during your
during your working life
that was pension i guess huh and this is
something different that was that you
could change at any time the name of
your beneficiary
zender fellows thank you
so the language that is being added here
says upon joining the retirement system
so the example that you gave
of getting married like two two years
after you joined the retirement system
this the word doesn't include what you
just described correct as i opened we do
need to amend this
to include
any existing member that was an
oversight when it was drafted
it left a gap between those that get
hired and those that are eligible folks
like me that are in the middle
were were inadvertently excluded from
this and that's an easy correction we'll
thank you
other questions
seeing none
thank you i'd
okay um for the record again marty
carlin representing the new hampshire
retirement system
nhrs doesn't have a position on the bill
we did prepare a handout
with some
background information on the bill but
while the change itself is fairly
straightforward
you know the
circumstances um you know the other
factors around it do seem to be a little
confusing so i'm going to sort of step
back you know 5 000 feet and kind of
walk back to this bill
right now
active members
are encouraged to fill out a beneficiary
form once they start working
and up they can update that beneficiary
form at any time throughout their career
you know that they want to change the
beneficiary um the form can either be
submitted online through their account
or they need to send us a notarized
paper form but um you know they can do
that
constantly if they would like
we try to encourage people to do that um
as much as we can and make sure it's you
know we say make sure you like the
person who's on that right now
if
an active member
dies while they're in service while
they're working and contributing there
are statutory death benefits available
in
rsa 100 a8 and a9
a8
refers to non-job-related death you know
a terminal illness not related to work
an accident
type of thing and then a9 is accidental
death benefits
and those are automatic
uh we paid to the beneficiary on file it
you know presuming there is one which um
and um you know we just need to be
notified of the death and the
circumstances to move that along
so that those those are existing sort of
automatic there's no paperwork a member
has to fill out to do anything uh you
know to make their beneficiary
it seems like representative she was
trying to signal you i wasn't didn't
want to interrupt her doesn't issue it
thank you madam chair thank you mr
carlin
with a new employee is there any
time limit that they have to have been
working
and
contributing into the retirement system
before any benefit can be paid to a
beneficiary uh yes and actually it may
be if the committee thinks it's of use i
can send you our uh handout on the death
the
statutory death benefits just for
background purposes basically please do
so a job a non-job-related death
if it occurs at any point in their
career the beneficiary would get the a
lump sum of the members contributions
refunded to them so the member money is
always going to go back to a beneficiary
if there is one
if the
non-job-related death if the member has
more than 10 years and is vested in the
pension system
a spouse beneficiary would have the
option of taking 50 of their pension as
calculated on the date of death or a
lump sum equal to their accumulated
contributions plus a year's salary
and statutorily that's only available to
a spouse beneficiary if you had a
non-spouse beneficiary a partner or a
child or
cousin or whatever they would get the
lump sum payment is would be their only
option
the spouse would have the option of
choosing whichever one made more sense
to them the job-related death benefits
accidental death um there's a it's a
um benefit let me read this um that
there's no minimum service for that so
if somebody
uh is killed early in their career and
you know in the line of duty uh there is
a benefit payable and i
literally just had that sheet in front
of me there it is
so for a group one member it's 50 of the
members average final compensation is
payable um
to a surviving spouse uh slightly
different for group two it's fifty
percent of the members annual rate of
earnable compensation in the year they
died so um that that might or might not
be a larger number but those those are
automatic benefits so that's sort of the
landscape on beneficiary designation
pre-retirement and death benefits
so what what this bill talks about is
something called pre-selection of a
survivorship option and that's under rsa
1813 not under the death benefit statute
and
add to the level of confusion it's the
same sentence that representative
goalie's bill addresses but it does
something completely different um you
know and they don't there's no overlap
between them so
what what right now the way that bill
a13 is uh phrased members who are
eligible for service retirement can
pre-select a survivorship option so this
is somebody who is eligible to retire
you know they're older than 60 in group
one or they have you know they're older
than six in group two or have their 45
and 20 46 and 21 etc and filling out
another
another form for the pre-selection if
they pass away while they're still
working the spouse would get 100 of
their pension as calculated you know on
on the date of their death
okay um so that obviously the 100
benefit is better than a 50 benefit but
the the member has to take an
affirmative action to fill out this form
and submit it to us and they all are
only allowed to do that once they're
eligible for service retirement so for
instance i'm not eligible for service
retirement i can't fill out a
pre-selection yet you know under the
current statute um you know the you know
there are issues with people who
are eligible and may not realize that
this benefit exists we try to we when we
do our
member education presentations we have a
slide on this
we include references to it in
newsletters we've done standalone emails
you know and and it's it's one of these
where you say this sounds to be good to
be true but it actually is it gives
someone who is continuing to work after
they're technically eligible to retire a
little more peace of mind if they pass
away
um you know the spouse would get a
larger benefit than
the automatic benefits under the other
statute so um what this bill would do
is allow members prior to service
retirement eligibility to designate that
pre-selection option
um it wouldn't take effect if you know
the person was you know 42 years old
when they died and they weren't eligible
for service retirement but you know a 22
year old could check the box on the
beneficiary form for this
and
40 years later you know it's still in
effect they don't have to
be told about it and remember to do it
once they they become eligible for
service retirement so
um you know so to the extent that some
people have already done these and some
people haven't this would make it easier
for more people to do this designation
right now it's two separate forms that
members have to fill out to do this the
regular beneficiary form and the
pre-selection
and um you know the names have to match
you can't have different beneficiaries
on those two forms uh under this bill if
if it's passed and it was
a version of this was floated in the
senate last year so so we looked at it
it was an amendment it wasn't a bill
that didn't advance um you know we could
combine the pre-selection as another box
on the regular beneficiary form so
throughout someone's career they can
update their beneficiary and
check or choose not to check the
pre-selection box at any time as well so
it would streamline the paperwork issue
involved in this
and you know fortunately you know there
are very few in-service deaths of our
members you know obviously there's some
higher profile you know tragedies that
go on but just you know dying of a
disease or in a car accident you know
we've you know averaged you know there's
probably you know 66 to 73 over the last
three years per year and not all of
those people are eligible for service
retirement this affects you know younger
members as well so
um
you know the actuary didn't see any kind
of cost issue with expanding this
because it's a it's such a small pool
out of a 48 000 active members
you know that that any additional
benefits that a
beneficiary would get
um you know wouldn't show up in the
rounding if you will on on the rates and
another difference is
the pre-selection allows you to
designate any beneficiary for this um
not just the spouse where
the the death benefits there's some
things that are only specific to a
spouse and obviously in 1968 that was
sort of the nuclear family model and
people may have different beneficiaries
now than they did then
so that
is sort of a bigger picture i'm glad to
try to answer any questions anybody has
about the bill
so the people that are affected that
would be
getting this additional benefit
are individuals who are not yet eligible
no they they
die in service
they have to be eligible for service
retirement and fill out the form you
know under this law so they it's almost
it's almost like a dormant benefit if
you're 30 years old and you check this
box and you die
so you don't get the benefit if you're
not eligible for service retirement the
pre-selection benefit is 100
you know to the beneficiary is only for
people who are service retirement
eligible under a13 so it it it's an
enhanced death benefit essentially but
it's only available if somebody dies
and is eligible for retirement
i think i would love to have your uh
information packet on this because i'm
getting thoroughly confused it and
actually i know i had stopped but i did
look at my notes i know representative
pearson addressed the
the uh the phrasing of any member or
point joining their retirement system
and we had a question whether the intent
was that anybody you know in their
career as you know any active member
could do this and would suggest
clarification on that
and also
there's a strikethrough in the bill
um online
same line where it strikes out uh
sections one and two of rsa 100 a5 and
refers only to a5
and 185 pertains to
both
service and early service retirement
benefits so it it seems like it would
as written open the universe of people
who could do receive something on the
pre-selection if a member who's eligible
for early service retirement passes away
that they would be payable to them too
and we just wanted to clarify if that
was
the intent if it was and then it's fine
the way it is um
in early service retirement real quickly
is it's you're collecting your pension
before your full retirement age and it's
reduced uh you know by factors you know
how far away you are from retirement how
long you worked
okay thank you for the question shoot
you have a follow-up
thank you madam chair
mr carlin i i will bring up another
scenario and i wonder if the
system has considered this
if an active member designates say their
spouse
and then just leaves that in the system
for years and years
and the spouse
passes away before
the employee
would that complicate things for the
retirement system if that's the
beneficiary
so the the the members beneficiary has
passed away and then the member dies in
service with that person never changed
yeah that that would
there would be no lifetime benefit
payable to anyone in that sense because
the the beneficiary of the the benefit
is also deceased but the refund of
contributions and those that that would
go to the estate and it would have to go
through the you know the probate process
representative
yes uh you had mentioned uh training
materials on all of this that is uh
provided to employees could you provide
that
to us and uh or a link to it or
something sure thing thank you
definitely necessary representative
o'brien
yeah thank you man i'm sure mr collins
just to clarify with uh representative
schuett's question
i think in my time that one can declare
multiple benefits if if i were to put
down my wife and then if i was fearful
of her passing in the future i could
name children or other who i choose am i
correct so the system allows multiple
beneficiaries yes i i did to try to keep
it sort of simple aside you know i was
talking about a single beneficiary but
the law allows a member to designate
multiple beneficiaries and assign a
percentage of the benefit to them to the
multiples
the law does limit that to any number of
your children and or your spouse so you
couldn't do you know three cousins it
would have to be one person but for the
sort of immediate family um you know you
you could allow multiple beneficiaries
and and there's also a provision
uh we're talking about beneficiaries
that's you know who the benefits are
payable to you can also designate what's
called the contingent beneficiary and if
your beneficiary has passed and you have
a contingent any lump sums would go to
that person no contingent beneficiary
would be eligible for a monthly benefit
but you know the whatever the whatever
is owed to the the members of the state
would go to the contingent beneficiary
so you can have those as well
and those they can be multiple
representative and then psychic
thank you madam chair so mr carlin
really
the purpose of this bill is to
address all these options
in the case that an employee dies before
he he retires or they retire
because
it clarifies what the
in a nutshell if you had two yeah yes
okay thank you
representative scitec
i was going to ask about multiple wives
but we'll save that for later um
the question that i have is
we
remind me please where
there was a while back we passed the
bill to allow
someone to get an ex-wife
beneficiary
off when is it necessary
without her permission when is it
necessary for a beneficiary to give a
spouse beneficiary to give permission uh
can you remind me of that circumstance
yeah um actually it's on one of the
notes i was referring to so i'm going to
go back to that just to make sure i've
given you the
correct answer um the the ability for a
member to um
sort of de-list the beneficiary actually
is is it's a non-spouse beneficiary that
can be taken off without their consent
that was one of the bills there was a
couple of bills about that um
going on if if it's a spouse beneficiary
and there's a divorce in which the
divorce decree
you know or settlement agreement doesn't
designate a portion of the pension to
the spouse you know we have to follow
what the divorce degree says but if it's
if it's a there's no pension
obligation to the ex-spouse
a retired member can take them off and
put another spouse on that was
one change to the
limited uh exceptions for
um changing your beneficiary after the
120 days and then there was another bill
it was either the year before or the
year after where it allowed
someone to take a non-spouse beneficiary
off
on their own
there's always been a provision where
the beneficiary themselves can renounce
ex-member who i think testified on the
bill you were talking about who
claimed he might have made a bad
decision with a you know a non-committed
relationship and was locked into the
beneficiary and that he was seeking that
change
yes thank you
thank you for your testimony other
questions
all right thank you we are
anxiously awaiting your uh training
materials i'll try to get them to you
this afternoon thank you
thank you madam chairman again for the
record members of the committee my name
is arthur beaudry i represent the new
hampshire state permanent firefighters
retirement association and i am here in
favor of
house bill 1497 as hopefully amended uh
mr collin uh pretty much summed up most
of the concerns
but um we we've i've actually seen it
firsthand in manchester where we had
firefighters that were thinking of
retiring they had their paperwork in
their desk and never went up the ledge
up the concrete and signed
their pre-option farm and they they
passed away
and their spouse ends up getting 50 with
if they signed that form they would have
gotten 100 of their of their uh pension
um
and with the demise uh the unfortunate
uh two suicides in manchester of young
individuals you know their their spouses
ended up losing out um if they didn't
sign those papers and instead of again
instead of 100 of that individual's
pension they would only get 50 percent
if they had over 10 years of service
so
you can
the way the existing lara is i could be
driving up the concave to sign my
pre-option form get in the car accident
and kill myself and my spouse ends up
losing 50 percent of my pension
with no really no fault of of the member
so um it is something that really should
be done and
this bill was put in in the senate last
year uh senator kavanaugh put it in i
think they tabled it
and we have to look at the death benefit
also because that is another concern
that was brought to my attention which
believe it or not i i was always under
the assumption
that if somebody dies in the line of
duty their spouse or beneficiary would
get 100 of their pay plus their money
and the members money back plus interest
and i was told now that it's they only
get 50
so um
i was going to ask mr collins if this if
we sign a pre-option form for a 100
percent benefit if i were to die in the
line of duty was would my spouse still
get a hundred percent of the benefit
instead of the 50 under the accidental
death so those are concerns um
and um
i would answer any questions and but i
we hope that this does get rectified
because it there's no sense in not
having to be able to pick an option uh
upon your
um hiring
especially if you if you're married and
you have children
that'll answer any questions all right
thank you for your testimony
representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming here and testifying uh that was
very well said and
just to clarify so this
basically allows someone to pre-select
ahead of time versus keeping an eye on
when their data is that they reach that
service age eligibility to have to drive
back up to concord when they go and do
their
spouses or survivorship options uh death
benefit they'll be able to do this at
the same time while it will not go in
effect until they reach that age they'll
at least have it done and not have to
keep looking at the clock as to when
they reach eligibility that's correct
representative thank you
other questions
okay see you done thank you thank you
very much
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is brian rill for the
record i serve as the president of the
professional firefighters of new
hampshire and i'm captain for the city
of portsmouth fire department
i am not the subject matter expert on
this material however i do have
the ability to uh somewhat simplify
things as i'm speaking as a firefighter
so um what this benefit
is
um
is actually just a
a safeguard for someone that is
has reached retirement eligibility
and has not filled out this
pre-selection form if they
continue to remain on the job
as a firefighter or
in the in the public sector and they
pass away while they're retirement
eligible
and have not filled out this form
their
spouse receives 50 percent of the
benefit they normally would have gotten
what this benefit is not
is it's not a new benefit
this is this is the benefit that has
been earned by our members
it is just ensuring that that benefit
carries on to their beneficiary uh so
it's extremely important um
hopefully madam chair i may be able to
speak to the question that you asked
earlier this does not uh allow a member
who
uh was
25 years old who came on the job checked
the box and say died at 30
this would not
push that benefit forward
they would have to sign the form at 25
years old then work their entire career
reach retirement service eligibility
for this to actually take place
so it does not create a benefit for
those that don't meet the requirements
under service eligibility
this is important to firefighters
specifically
due to the changes that we talked about
earlier in 2011 firefighters are having
to work longer careers they're having to
work 5 10 15 years longer than they
normally would have
which puts them in a position
that they may be more
susceptible to
passing away prior to retirement
it's extremely
important that we make sure that we take
care of the families in this situation
and provide the benefit that has been
earned by each of these members
so for those reasons i urge you to
support hp 1497 and would be happy to
answer any questions that you may have
thank you for your testimony i have a
question is it limited to group two is
it for all members of the system
so this should be for all members of the
system thank you representative product
thank you madam chair
um
our
our um
employees when they reach this 10-year
limit
is it up to them solely to um
be aware of that date or are they sent a
reminder or
so um
this may be a
question that mr carlin may be able to
answer the way i understand it is it's
not once you are vested in the system
it's once you meet your time and age to
retire
which for someone like me would be
25 years and age 45. i see
but to answer your questions
specifically
i can tell you that while educating
firefighters throughout the state that's
all i'm familiar with there are many
folks that are retirement eligible that
are unaware of this
process
and i know mr carlin mentioned that
there's some educational materials that
they provide i will say that um
i've had to search for them to find them
they're not
short of us putting them in front of our
members faces a lot of them haven't seen
it
follow up please
thank you and so in light of the
previous um earlier bill
would this make
our
jobs
offerings
more desirable would it improve
at all
what
how the perception of the retirement
system or we just do nothing
uh thank you for the question i think
by answering that i'm certainly going to
be speculating but i would say that
certainly if someone who's been in the
system
is not overly educated on the matter
someone who has no time in the system
would probably struggle to to have that
education as well so it may not make a
okay thank you
for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on house bill 1497
madam chair if i can interrupt for just
a brief moment
i just would like to acknowledge
a very nearly honorary member of this
committee whom we haven't seen for quite
a while
major ernest loomis is with us today
thank you
we've i've already spoken with the major
this bill will also be going to the
pension subcommittee it's got got some
issues and definitely needs at least one
amendment
all right
is there any other member of the public
that wishes to
testify seeing none i will close the
public hearing and we are in recess
you
so
good afternoon welcome back
i'm opening the hearing on house bill
1549 and i call representative tracey
emerick
thank you madam chair
my name is tracy amrick
represent rockingham district 21 which
is hampton
house bill 1549
i know you've heard this before is a
this deals with special duty
employment of police officers
and strictly that
the current situation is prior to
retirement special duty details which
are like
working at a construction site handling
traffic or
escorting a wide load or anything
non-enforcement duties non-law
enforcement duties
special duty does not count towards
retirement
so if your pre-retirement all your
special duty time does not count for
your retirement
however
once you retire
special duty time does count towards
your retirement
so
once you retire and you have your
ceiling and whatever it is i'm not going
to get into the retirement system i
tried to open that book
and said i'm not going to go there
because i i'm certainly not going to be
an expert on the state retirement system
whatever your deal is whenever you
retired under
all i'm asking all this bill does is say
if you do a special duty it does not
count against your retirement hours or
pay
a very and if you read the bills
short
uh it says that
those payments would be handled not
charged against retirement
and that's the upshot
thank you representative eric
are there any questions representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair and welcome
colleague
um
i say colleague because he's on the jcec
with me along with representative scitec
um
but uh so if you're not an expert on the
um retirement system
and neither are we
nobody's an expert on the retirement
system they all have an opinion uh but
uh if you're not an expert on it where
did you come up with the idea for this
bill the bill was the idea was given to
me by our
retired police chief who is now on the
rockingham county sheriff's department
other questions representative pierce i
think you may have chaired
and uh this may
not be something you can answer
and if that if you can't that's okay
special duty
who
is there is there a clear definition of
what that entails
of what is defined as special duty
versus something else well i did
some homework on it and it is primarily
duties which do not include law
enforcement
it's like escorting over a wide
oversized load or
working in a construction site alongside
the road and doing traffic management uh
it's not you know you you don't go out
and arrest people on special duty that
uh hi representative
the expert is sitting in the back of the
room on the retirement system good
all the questions should be directed
there here's my question these are
you're basically talking details
i'm sorry police details police details
yes okay the question i have is um
the
do they retain police powers when
they're doing this if they see something
going on are they obligated as police
officers to break up a fight uh stop an
assault something like that i would
assume so
i i that i can't answer i i don't know
you see my my question is that if
if they're not police officers i'm
acting as police
they're sort of compromised are they
wearing two hats when they're doing this
watching a construction site
that's going to take a bigger mind than
mine
other questions representative rose
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question
this is i think going to piggyback on
what representative scitec was asking
but a very good friend of mine is a
police chief in in
a town here in new hampshire and he
often speaks of when there are not
enough officers in a particular town
that of course a neighboring town can
come to detail for that town so that of
course there is coverage
so if the police officer is you know in
in town a and just coming over to help
town because it's a neighboring town
that's considered a detail so
would would that
would that count as
you know this here because they're
certainly working in the capacity if
if they were needed whereas you know
traffic detail as as far as a
you know construction crew is a little
bit different i think what you're saying
it would apply if they were retired
all right
thank you
other questions representative bailey
i'm trying to figure out what would the
uh representative pearson was telling us
the other day that everything had to be
either solving a problem or
there was a couple different categories
but
what what is this solving it's like what
you don't want it counted towards the
retirement system is that to avoid the
unfunded balance no
with the retirement system it has to do
with how many hours they can work
there's a limit there's a limit on a
retiree how many hours they can work
without going back into a full-time
status
i see thank you and what that does is
allow people that are kind of at the
ceiling
of their retirement status being able to
do special duty
and not have it count against the
retirement status
i mean
follow-up
i mean do you sort of
are you not really retired if you're
working 40 hours of detail work or you
know
i don't that you'll have to talk to the
retirement system on that one that yeah
okay thank you above my paid grade
representative
representative bailey asked the question
for me
how efficient
representative fellow
thank you um i'm just wondering on line
five what what is the distinction about
a permanent
policeman
i can actually help with that if he
can't
and it defines what a permanent
a permanent policeman is someone who is
eligible to be in group two as a as a
policeman
it is defined elsewhere in the statutes
other questions
all right
thank you very much mr carlin if you
could help straighten us all the mess
thank you madam chair and again for the
record marty carlin representing the new
hampshire retirement system
excuse me we don't have a position on
this bill and i signed up to just
provide some background i think
i would agree with representative
emmerich that this is
fairly straightforward in terms of
retirement system world but just just to
again give a little bit higher up view
to see how this plays in
under the current law nhrs retirees who
begin working part-time for a
participating employer
after july 1 of 19
are
limited to a maximum of 1352 hours in
the calendar year it's not a weekly
limit it's an it's a calendar year limit
and the
employers are required to track hours
work by retirees and report them to us
at the beginning of the following year
so right now
we're still in the window to get 20 21
numbers from the employers
if they go over 1352 there's a penalty
there's a pension offset for 12 months
which is the state's portion of their
pension which could be a significant
penalty
um
there's a grandfathering provision for
retirees who were working in a position
prior to 1 1-1 of 19 they can work
1664 hours but you know
as long as they stay in that position so
um and uh
detail pay is included in the hours
reported for retirees just just to kind
of clarify
because there are some differences
among active members on whether uh
the detail pay is earnable compensation
so for anyone who's hired
on or after july 1st of 11
detail pay does not count they don't
contribute on and it doesn't contribute
toward their pension uh it does count as
compensation over base
to go back to 1587 this morning for
members who were in the system prior to
um 7-1 of 11 and weren't vested for one
one of 12 and then the
the original uh class of of vested
members also
get detail as part of their pension so
um let's see uh so
in terms of there is a definition in rsa
100 a
uh of extra or special duty pay that it
means member work activities or details
for which the employer bills or charges
another entity in whole or in part for
the work activities or detail provided
so again this is a
hiring law enforcement uh you know for
tree cutting work you know on a busy
street things like that and you know the
member or the retiree is paid by the
employer but that you know it's it's
through you know the phone company or
whoever's
authorizing the work so the only um
question i had with the language of the
bill was it refers um
to um special duty law enforcement
not extra special duty pay so just to
clarify and from what the sponsor said
that was his intention but that would be
preferable to clarify that so
an employer couldn't create a class of
pay called special duty law enforcement
just to get somebody out of the hours
because there already is a definition of
detail in the statute so it would be
better
in 2020 which is the last number
uh year that we have data for with 374
retirees working in police positions
um some of them may do detail some may
not
type of thing and to the question
someone asked
earlier
i don't
know if they have arrest powers or they
can chase somebody who's you know
driving by them at 120 or whatever that
it's outside the retirement system
purview so i never really did any
research on
um you know if they have full
law enforcement powers but maybe there's
somebody here who can clarify that but i
can't answer that
so i'd be glad to address any questions
anybody has
thank you madam chair thank you mr
carlin
could you
tell me is the
site in the last on line seven of the
bill is that
the
site in 100a that defines
the detail that you were just talking
about or is there a different
you just said 100a can you give us the
specifications yeah the specific that is
not that that that section of the
statute specifically refers to the
annual reporting by employers okay um
all of the working after retirement it's
it's it's grafted on to several
different statues but the ex the
definition of extra or special duty pay
is an rsa 100 a one
uh section 32 32 and that was that was
put in i think 2009 or so
thank you
follow-up question is
[Music]
do you have any kind of estimate as to
how many
police officers
who began before that july 1st 2011
date are still on the job
just a rough um
trying to remember from last week's bill
that
um
about 1800 i think that there was that
many yeah that still
they they i'm sorry they were in service
prior to seven one of eleven so they're
still working and still
accruing detail pay is part of that comp
over base
umbrella that we spoke about this
morning on the
other and one more follow-up
so
if if a retiree
came and worked those detail hours
they could possibly be
[Music]
what's the word deferring those on
on the job officers who could be
utilizing that
time
towards their retirement
if
to the extent that you know detail hours
are available to police departments it's
the local authorities who decide who to
assign them to and you know what what
the needs are so i i couldn't
specifically say yes or no to that i
wouldn't thank you i have enough
information
if i were to calculate 352
hours per year
it ends up at on a 52 year week year
it's 26 hours a week correct
so
retirees are allowed to work up to 26
hours a week
without affecting their pension benefit
yes is that correct yes and that was
effective july 1 2011. that's when we is
put into statute for 352 hours no that's
the that 1352 took effect on january 1st
of 19 there was
previously there was a weekly limit of
32 hours a week that was put in in 11
and that was amended to make it an
annual limit at a lower weekly average a
few years back
okay
i
follow up i'm sorry
i know in my own time we have a whole
pecking order of who gets plea police
detail and is that a function of the
municipality as opposed to some place in
statute yeah i i don't know of any
statutory governing that i
so i won't guess but you know it seems
like it will guess
thank you it's a municipal
the police department decides who gets
the details
and as was said they frequently ask
around for neighboring towns if they
need a lot of people on the highway for
guarding utility trucks or whatever
senator pearson and then go
thank you thank you madam chair
so
during the
this period of time where
in which we're discussing here
folks
folks are retired so they're collecting
a pension benefit
while they're doing this they're
3 13 52 maximum hours
or you know
or any of these special details
is anything being taken out of their pay
to contribute into the system for the
job that they are working on no no thank
you
representative goalie and then schmidt
thank you man chair thank you marty for
you made the statement earlier that you
were
unsure whether their special duties
would be
included law enforcement activities
isn't it pretty clear on line five that
it states
any hours worked on special duty law
enforcement would allow them
to provide law enforcement while they're
doing this
again not as a
lawyer it seems like it but there may be
other statutes you know defining that
you know in the public safety statutes
that may
i'm not sure you know that it's it's on
its face yes
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so are we potentially opening any doors
you have to be an expert
you're the only one
to
to recognize
you're going down the wrong path here
to clarify i wouldn't call myself an
expert i've just been around a while um
but you know the
unintended consequences similar to the
bill
last week that would increase it to
1664. only to the extent that full-time
positions are eliminated because there's
more hours available to work for
retirees this is limited to law
enforcement detail pay
again because all the hours are reported
as hours not broken out we don't know
how many hours folks are working for
that um you know for statistical
purposes that separate report contained
in this bill could guide the legislature
to look at down the road if if they seem
to be any unintended consequences but
follow it so i mean
it sounds to me like they're doing a lot
of
kind of what's called traffic detail
here
[Music]
civilians are hired to do this kind of
thing in many cases
but
what you have to do is you have to know
something about managing traffic which
police are trained to do and
and civilians learned how to do
so
um it doesn't seem like really police
work
like
where you have to know something about
police practices and policing
so i
that's the reason for my question and
can we think in those terms and and then
it doesn't
i'm not sure that that's a a question
but
i i know i i wasn't i was about to say
the same thing i'm not sure what the
question was it's you know that
there are no obvious unintended
consequences that the retirement system
thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question i
actually have two very short questions
the first i think i know the answer to
and the second i think i'm really
baffled on
the the first is is
what is the rationale
behind placing a cap
on the number of hours that can be
worked in a nutshell as best you can in
a nutshell it
before 2011 uh the definition part time
was anything less than full time so you
could theoretically have folks working
39 and a half hours a week collecting a
full pension and essentially doing
a position that we're not getting any
contributions on that you know arguably
you know should be a contributing uh
position going forward so the
legislature lowered that to a weekly
limit and then adjusted it again in 2018
but you know the the policy argument
that i heard when these bills were being
put forward is
you know you you know you could take an
employer could go to an entirely
part-time workforce you know if they
were working you know 35 hours a week
you know it's really part time in name
only for most people at that
level of hours and then not pay any
contributions into the retirement system
and those
liability costs would be spread among
everyone else in the system so that was
sort of the impetus to to define a
number of hours for retirees that was
truly part-time and part of the reason
32 was brought up again in 2018 lowered
was under the affordable care act
anything over 30 hours a week you
qualify for health care anyway so that
most employers had already moved to a
lower uh weekly limit because of that
outside of our statutes and my follow-up
please please
so i understand what the bill is trying
to do but why should these hours not
count against that cap you know that's
that's a policy decision um if if
employers
you know
who are using part-timers feel like
there's not enough hours to get these
jobs done you know and they they could
speak to you about you know the reason
but it's
you know i i
don't have a reason for or against the
change um you know but it would be a
policy decision
and obviously employers reached out to
the sponsor on that uh but
i don't have an answer for that one
representing fellows
thank you um let me just go through a
scenario so
we'll see if i understand
what's going on here
suppose a police officer
retired in 2017
with
you know whatever 30 years of service
and
he's receiving his retirement payment
under this
he could be working
26 hours a week
plus he could in in when and when he
earned his retirement those hours
special duty was included in that yes it
was so his retirement was based on his
regular hours plus any special duty
hours he had so now he could be working
part-time he could be working 26 hours
and then he could be working another
15 special duty hours
which wouldn't count if we passed this
and he could actually he'd be taking
yes a short answer is yes i don't know
how often that would occur but yes yes
yes thank you madam chair
uh following a question
of one of members here
how many hours can a retired police
officer
can work on duty
on detail i'm sorry
well it it's there's no specific limits
on detail right now for retirees it's
any hours worked whether it's you know
for the law enforcement agency or the
town
uh you know or you know or detail it's
the total is 1352 hours in a year
and again this is only for a
participating employer obviously learned
for there are no non-member law
enforcement outfits but a retiree could
work full-time in another career and
collect a pension and that's okay it's
this limit is for
working for a participating
employer they could also work full-time
for the police and lowell representative
thank you and oh my goodness okay so i
almost forgot my question um it's but a
currently
a current police officer who's not
retired
can work as many detail hours as they
wish so there's
employee it's only on the retired
employee correct
yeah there's there's no limit on how
many hours an active group two member
could or any member could work uh detail
anybody who joined the retirement system
on or after seven one of eleven that
detail pay doesn't count towards the
pension anybody who is in the system and
before that date and still active you
know they do that does go towards their
pension calculation but there's no limit
on the hours
okay thank you
president o'brien
thank you madam chair
thank you mr collins for taking a
question
what concerns me with this well
they are a police officer they have to
meet certain qualifications
whether it be
target range shooting
other different things physicals and
stuff like that but once a person is
retired
they're basically out of the system
do you
know of anybody who would get hired
under this situation
does the police department have any
standards for these particular people to
meet the qualifications because i
imagine some of this why wouldn't it be
anybody off the street i think they want
somebody with a gun
and if that is the case are they meeting
the qualifications that they would as a
police officer
nothing under the retirement system law
governs that i am aware just from past
bills that there are there are full-time
and part-time certification for police
officers through police standards and
there's different
levels of qualification for a full-time
certification versus a part-time
so um
you know you know and i i don't know
specifically whether a town could call
someone law enforcement or they need to
have
them you know have the sort of requisite
certification from police standards i
don't know the answer to that
follow-up follow up with that being said
and very well explained but just to make
sure
in other words the new hampshire
retirement system would just take it
that this person is retired and working
under this without any knowledge whether
they met that particular qualifications
that's the responsibility of the
employer
yes
i don't see any other questions mr
carlin so you're off the hook for this
one
good afternoon madam chairman members of
the committee again for the record my
name is arthur beaudry i represent the
new hampshire state permanent
firefighters retirement association and
we are here in opposition of house bill
for the same reasons that we were in
opposition of house bill 1079 last week
um
if it walks like a duck and quacks like
a duck it's a duck um you can change the
names
in manchester uh where i come from
um they have auxiliary police officers
they have full uh arrest rights and they
carry a weapon and but they uh fall
under the 1300 hour rule
so you can change this name to anything
but
our concern is when the municipal
association comes in and says they're in
in support
of having part-time workers to save
money but then they come in on other
bills and say that the system is broken
and it's unfunded liability is out of
control
well this plays into it because if you
don't have money going into the system
to invest
the unfunded accrued liability will
never get paid off so
if these individuals like to continue to
keep working they can keep working as a
full-time police officer
they don't have to retire and go work as
an auxiliary or as a what they would
call a special duty law enforcement i
question personally
why would they
want somebody other than a
police officer that could actually have
arrest rights if that's the case you
could hire
a traffic company that would go out and
take care of traffic for probably half
the cost that they would be charging
the police officers so
i would assume that they would want a
police officer that has arrest rights
and
has the powers to to
keep keep the public
at bay so i will answer any questions
but those are the reasons why we are
opposed to it and
it may be small but it does impact the
system and we truly want to get the
system into 100
thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman
so my understanding
and i'm speaking of again my my friend
that i've been talking to a lot
that is the police officer
my understanding is if you're a
full-time police officer
you're not allowed to say you know i'm
not working christmas day i'm not
working after
you know nine o'clock at night
whereas
one of the questions asked is well why
would you retire or you don't have to
retire so if you retire of course you
can say
no i'm not working christmas day or i'm
not working on tuesdays
so is that correct that if you're
full-time you pretty much have to work
when you're told you're going to work
versus
i can explain that as a firefighter
because we have very limited um
special duty but that is that's pretty
much voluntary you go on a list and they
pick off a list you're not mandatory to
go because i i know
that they have when they don't have
enough police officers in manchester
they they go and hire the county
sheriffs to come in and take over
because they don't have enough police
officers volunteering to do the work so
to answer your question at least in
manchester i believe it's
not mandatory it's it's you're on a list
and they pick off the list for whatever
details you want
but it's not a mandatory thing if they
can tell you to work your eight-hour
shift if they don't if a police officer
calls in sick i'm assuming they can say
hey you got to cover that shift but to
tell you you've got to go out and follow
a tree company around because they're
cutting trees down i don't believe they
any other questions from the committee
person goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
you've been around here long enough as
we've discussed a number of hours that
should be worked
after retirement
and we've had
it continue to go down
do you believe
either or the number of hours per week
or a set number per year or do you think
a set number per week should suffice
instead of
having the hours per year
i think the week would be better and i
as i testified on house bill 1070 79
at least
as a
school board member i saw firsthand
teachers and principals working
full-time
um under under the law because it was at
the even at 32 hours they only work
seven seven hour days five days a week
so they could pretty much work full-time
and claim
that uh you know it's part-time work so
i would
see the hours a week would be better and
again reduce it from less than 30
because under the affordable care act um
30 hours above is considered full time
so
as i stated again in house bill 1079
we would like to see 20 hours a week
thank you representative
thank you
mr beaudry if we did it by the hours
though how would you um
manage the let's just take the police
details for example the um
seasonality of the work in the summer
i mean again
these departments and
one of the departments that used to come
before when we've been dealing with this
as uh
committeeman goalie had mentioned this
has been going on for decades but
hampton beach they say in the summer
they need a lot of a lot of police
officers well if they know that they
should start working ahead of time
to get those police officers
so they have enough to accommodate what
their needs are
they have basically a whole year to do
that
so
follow up
so as as the budget committee chair for
my town
i would be very remorse if my police
department
hired
a lot of officers in the summer
and then had
them not
needing them in the winter
i'm not saying full-time people i'm
saying podcast oh okay all right i'm so
sorry
okay all right
anyway thank you that's okay i
understand to get there
get steamed up about it
season that seasonal work is
the main reason that we chose to make it
an annual limit so that a person could
work full time in the summer and then
take the winter take off the rest of the
year
all right seeing none
i don't have any cards is there any
other person who would like to testify
all right seeing none i'm going to close
the public hearing
and our next hearing is at two
i have a question of the chair man i'm
sure it has nothing to do with this this
bill but if you look at today's agenda
you see
what's that
well that's right it refers to a whole
bunch of bills that ain't on the list
for today
i don't think there's any one of them i
so when when are the i have in special
interest in one of the bills which is
uh 1552
it's on the 31st at
you
good afternoon we are going to open the
the committee recognizes representative
mcguire
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire representing
merrimack district 29 the towns of
allenstown epsom and pittsfield
and house bill 1563
came out of my experience on the
decennial commission on the pensions
where
we
essentially agreed that a
regular cost of living increase for the
retirement system
would be
too expensive to plan for
and so
this is a
best practices from private industry
it signs up
members new new hires
into the deferred compensation plan
which is a tax advantage savings plan
and
at a two percent rate and then it
automatically escalates everyone in the
system
by
or 25 dollars if they're on the dollar
rate
and so what this does is it
lets
employees
save for their retirement tax advantaged
because many people as turned out have
if they get to retire and they don't
have any significant savings on of their
own
or they enrolled in the
deferred compensation plan at five
dollars a week
and 30 years later they're retiring and
they're still putting in five dollars a
week which is
better than nothing but not as good as
it could have been
and many people just don't bother to
sign up
so this automatically signs them up
escalates it
but with the caveat that if any person
wants something else and
tells the system that they're exempt so
if
their their free choice is what
sets the limits
this just changes the default to be
contribute at a at a modest level to
start and then escalating to a fairly
substantial one
representative grota
thank you um madam chair representative
mcguire so at this time
this
program is available
it's purely
it's voluntary yes and follow-up
and this bill makes it mandatory
correct well you you always be signed up
if you choose you can
sign yourself back out
you can sign yourself back out yes
without a sorry without a penalty yes
without penalty and without a
an alternative plan
correct
okay thank you
representative
the the you don't need an alternative
plan this applies to state employees
they're already covered by the defined
benefit pension this is a supplement
thank you um
just to clarify a few things make sure i
understand it when you say it's
mandatory it's mandatory that
that they be included in the plan unless
they opt out but that's if the employer
chooses to offer it at all is that
correct yes the basic bill is mandatory
for state employees
for
towns and so forth that enroll their
employees in
this plan which is allowed may adopt
so as i understand it
the money put into this
retirement account
is just from the employer the employee
does not contribute
is that correct no it's the other way
around it's all from the employee the
employer at least the state does not
contribute
okay
thank you
nothing bars them from contributing but
as of yet they have not never yet chosen
uh
thank you madam chair
so
as
as a state retired state employee
even though it was like 35 years ago i
remember when i first started work they
told me about the the deferred comp plan
right off the bat
and you know made it clear that you know
it was optional and you could put your
money in or not
i think one of my concerns
one concern is that
i think that when state employee i'll
just speak from the perspective of state
employees when
when they have to put seven percent of
their
their salary into the retirement system
to
require them to put another percentage
into another system
and then with the automatic escalation
knowing that a lot of employees are fi
are hired at the lowest labor grade and
they frequently get
a step increase after one year and then
they could get a cost of living increase
that same year it seems to me that
there's a potential like in three years
they can be right up to that maximum
seven percent and so i'm
in that case that's that's a good thing
right
unless they're so highly paid that they
reach the irs limit before then
um i'm i'm just wondering if if you gave
some consideration
to the fact that when young people
start work
that one of the first things they might
want to do is buy a house and to put
their money into this system
and once you put it in you can't take it
out without a penalty
that that might not be in their best
interest
that's correct and that's why
the bill
clearly specifies in several places that
if they opt out of the system or they
opt out of the automatic escalations
they're out
there's no question about it
and and to be honest
in my experience in the private sector
the same thing troll holds true most
people
most young people starting a job don't
so
just to clarify when you say out
then they're out of
contributing more to the system but
their money's in there and once it's in
the deferred comp until you get to
retirement age isn't there a penalty to
get your money out of that system um
i believe there's that there is a
penalty if you
unless you leave state employee or
something like that you mr downing is
here i can answer that and that in
detail i'm not up on on it
um
but yes it's it is
hell is the same as if you put it into a
an ira or whatever it's
it's money put aside and you can choose
to do so
you can choose not to do so if you think
representative marsh then schuette
uh thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question it's it's been my
experience uh as uh treasurer of our
local hospital and uh in directing our
retirement plan that employees who have
a self-directed retirement plan may not
always have
um
good knowledge as to what are good
choices for putting their funds into to
invest for their future retirement
how are the choices that the the
investment choices of the
deferred compensation plan made and what
advice are the participants given
i can't answer that in detail i do know
that the default
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
my
i'm i first of all will say i'm a
retired state employee also
and
i
actively participated in the deferred
comp program
very glad that i did
my problem with this bill though is
number one
the mandatory amounts
when i started
i wasn't making very much money and so i
was glad that
i could get in for just the five dollar
per paycheck
entry fee if you will representative
schuett is there a question
yes okay
but
i question the
automatic increment increases
my own circumstances changed about
halfway through my employment
my husband passed away and
suddenly all the bills fell on my one
salary
and i think it do you not agree that it
should be up to the employee
to decide how much they can afford
absolutely and that's why the employee's
decision overrides any default this just
sets the defaults what happens if
if you don't care or you don't
make an effort to change it so
half a percentage point of your raise
is
you know not you can live with that
because it only applies when you're
getting a
um a regular raise it's not
the
the system is
is such that
when there's a general raise for all
employees
the the the rates would be increased
and the dollar amount 25 dollars per pay
period
i thought that was fairly low if you
think five dollars up is is more
appropriate i'm
i'm not prepared to i don't know how
many people are
deducting fixed dollar amounts rather
than a percentage of pay
thank
you
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair
and thank you representative for taking
the question
looking at the past history
of the new hampshire retirement system
and
i kind of like the the basic idea of
what you're trying to do but let's look
over the years
we took what an employee in group two
was paying nine and three-quarter
percent raised it up to 11 point
something percent
we also changed the ull rules to
municipalities
okay and that's coming in from them
and then we're going to make this
mandatory to the employees
in other words you got to take the
earnable income that they currently have
make it mandatory to contribute to
something that should have been already
that wasn't
in the past this is not actually related
to the new hampshire retirement system
it is a completely independent system
it's more like a
when when i was working i had both a
defined benefit pension and a 401k
and i contributed to both of them
and so
the pension is as you know defined
benefit pensions are it's fixed
the
401k money has been
invested fairly well and i'm living
quite comfortably thank you
so and i and after listening to stories
about people that as i said put in five
dollars a week forever
and you know kind of regretted it
i i said well this is what
the research in the private sector says
is the best thing to do to help people
safe make it easy for them to save
and if they have other arrangements or
they can't afford it or whatever
fine they're out that's that's their
business but it just makes it easier for
them
ah thank you and you know i totally
agree with you because i was an active
participant in what we call the d comp
program and i'm glad that i did
uh but
like others have brought up again
looking yeah to me you do have to look
at collectively other things have
happened
and now to come on with this the money
got to come from somewhere and that's
definitely well the point is that if you
want to save if any person wants to have
some money of their own when they retire
why
it should be in a tax-deferred
retirement plan
for as long as possible just
to avoid giving a third of it to the
feds i mean that's that's only common
sense
and most people
either particularly if they're young
when they start working they don't think
about it they don't worry about it you
know they may sign up once when they're
you know filling out the forms at their
uh
orientation but
they don't think about increasing it
when their pay goes up
and so if they do think about it
more power to them let them do it but an
awful lot of people don't think about it
thank you and thank you madam chair
representative schuett
thank you
just going further with
someone who's in the same
type of situation that i was
if suddenly your income is dramatically
altered
what you need to spend it for
if
you feel that you can't afford
any kind of increment increase
after you get a pay increase then you
have to drop out of the system no you
can drop out of automatic escalations
and maintain your contribution at the
same level but you
or you could drop out of being able to
go forward and and put in
in the future sure you could
the the system right now already allows
employees to
join at any time right stop at any time
okay i'm i'm misinterpreting the
language i guess then thank you
or if it's if it's written wrong i will
i'll
i
it's been known to happen that and based
we'll have to talk okay representative
fellows
thank you
um
i was
i
i'm sure you're aware but just to check
that are you aware of the fact that when
you get close to retirement age when you
get close to age 65 if you have a
deferred comp plan
that you can put a significant amount of
money
into that plan within like you know
three three to five years if you haven't
if you haven't been putting in large
amounts all along
and that for some people that might be a
better arrangement
actually the best arrangement is to put
the money aside while you're young so it
has time to compound
but yes i am aware that you can put more
in when you're older i think you can put
more in when you're over 50
not necessarily how close you are to
retirement it's based on calendar age
but and but those are already in the
plan there's a maximum limit that the
irs sets and it goes up as you get older
but
i don't i don't need to replicate the
entire plan document with all the irs
follow-up
um
i
i'd also like to ask if don't you think
that some people might have the opinion
that there are better ways to use your
money than to put it into a deferred
comp which is mostly like mutual fund
kind of thing
because there are if you get the timing
right it's significant opportunities in
stock to invest in stock for example if
you had bought some stock in march of
at the end of march of 2019 you might be
well have like three times as much as
you
paid those for those stocks at this time
i
i don't know all the investment
options under the plan but i believe
they do offer stocks you can ask the
director of the plan
he was here representative bailey
oh thank you
um
i i like the plan i just i just had one
kind of softball question for you how
did you choose between
in and opt out
that was due to
the literature about
nudging
so that what it is is it it says that
a lot of people won't take action so if
you have an opt-in system which is what
they have and have for quite a while
only those who really
really care will bother to opt in
if you have it opt out a lot of people
will not care enough to opt out
so they will save
regard despite themselves
thank you follow up i guess mark a
comment we have seen today some opt-in
things that were a problem right that
people weren't opting in as they should
that is
that is the
experience
throughout the public and private sector
is that if it's an opt-in plan for
saving most people will not bother to
opt in
thank you
representative lucas
thank you um isn't it the case that if
somebody decides that they don't like
the
investment options provided here they
could just as well
open up ira with fidelity or somebody
and invest however they like rather than
using this plan absolutely and that's
the point is that this is
this is a default it's for the
[Music]
essentially the least common denominator
thank
thank you representative
are there any members from the public
sing none we will close the hearing for
house bill 1563 i apologize madam chair
i had thought the director of the
deferred compensation plan would be here
and i am going to
you